i'll tell you a quick childhood story
i'll tell you one of the funnier ones
right
one time when i was like six my older
brother was eight
we were in the back seat of my dad's car
and we were like laughing and we were
excited
because it was around christmas right
and my dad just had this thing he he
just didn't like joy
you know so he's sitting there driving
he's going like jesus christ knock it
off back there
christian don't straighten up i'm gonna
buy you a doll for christmas
and then he did
i swear to god he made us hold him up my
mother's taking pictures in front of the
christmas tree
i'm just standing there like
afterwards i ran upstairs to my top bunk
my dad knew
he [ __ ] up to his credit he came up he
tried to smooth it over he's like all
right come on back down
it's over come on down and enjoy the
holiday
and i'm like why did he dance i [ __ ]
hate you
right he eventually coaxed me down you
know
he just he softened up a little bit look
you don't get your [ __ ] ass back
downstairs
no one else can open that gift i'm
moving out i said moving out
i go back downstairs all shell shocked
here's another gift for you billy i'm
like
is this a [ __ ] dollhouse when does it
end
yeah that was christmas and those were
people that loved me
now you know what it is i didn't have
like a really good model necessarily
like growing up like watching my parents
they always used to argue and [ __ ] you
know
like i was afraid of my dad when i was
growing up you know anybody have a dad
like that you're just afraid of them
you know not like those sitcom dads they
come home the kids are like hugging
their legs
my dad pulls in the driveway me my
brother's freak's like [ __ ] dad's
home
shut off the tv try to hide dude if i
stand like this do i look like a lamp
he won't see me right can i just [ __ ]
chill out here
[Applause]
he wasn't understanding when you [ __ ]
up he told you
you didn't sit down while we're gonna
work it out we'll just you know i still
love you
you what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
jesus christ you're an idiot weren't you
even paying
attention now [ __ ]
christ you're just like your mother
you're [ __ ] out to lunch
that was my dad no matter what he was
bitching about somehow he would make it
about my mother
it would have nothing to do nothing to
do with her he could somehow
find a connection and spin it back he
just said i was it raining out
for christ's sake i don't need this [ __ ]
christ it's the same goddamn thing with
your mother
that woman is a [ __ ] cloud hanging
over my life
anytime you got an idea twice she shits
all over it
[Applause]
no he was hilarious he used to work all
the time so he didn't really have like
any friends or anything he used to talk
to me
when i was eight years old like i was a
[ __ ] bartender
just dumping all his [ __ ] on me like
playing in the sandbox he'd be coming up
tyrion i don't know what the [ __ ] i ever
got married for
i'll tell you man i'm gonna get the [ __ ]
out i swear to god one of these days
when get in the car
i'm gonna [ __ ] drive out of here your
mother's a [ __ ] billy do you realize
that the woman
is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
is that too real for you guys you
[ __ ] know what i'm talking about
you know i was trying to because i knew
a lot of [ __ ] to talk about uh
this week um
other than just being completely blown
away that my daughter's already a year
old
i can't believe it and uh i got her up
this morning
you know and i just couldn't believe how
big she was i was already thinking like
she used to be able to fit like her head
would go from my elbow not even to the
tips of my fingers like
i could just hold her just like that
now she's just she she's huge
what happened you know
there's nothing i can now see why people
have a bunch of kids because you keep
want to hit
reset there's nothing better than having
a
baby around your house it's the greatest
it's like a puppy times a million
um but what is cool is she's starting to
talk
so i'm waiting for these uh the
conversation because some of the kids my
god they were hilarious
um there was this little boy right and
he was talking to this
they wanted to see like outside my house
like along the side so i go all right
i'll take you over there just be careful
because you know
there's all these concrete steps and
[ __ ] i don't want somebody falling down
so uh he points to the side of the house
he goes what's this
and uh i go oh that's the back of the
chimney and it was a little kid he goes
what's that
and then the little girl answers she
goes that's where santa claus comes down
and the smoke goes up when you have a
fire
then i think the little kid like the
girl and he goes uh he says to me he
goes
does she live here and i started the
answer the girl once again answered the
question
she goes no she goes i live out in the
desert and the boy goes
in the sand she goes no
what the heck
[Applause]
kid was bombing i was pulling for him i
was like
you know say something funny make her
laugh
whatever i just like that he was working
on his game at like four years of age
um which reminded me when i was a little
kid
i liked this girl who lived in my
neighborhood
so i just went over a house not even
invited i just went over her house
knocked on the door
i think her name was michelle i knocked
in the door and her mom answers i was
like yeah hey is michelle home she goes
yeah she's in there watching tv
and i go okay so i went in there
and i sat down and watched tv
with her her mother and i think her
younger sibling and i never said a word
for like an hour i just sat there
watching teeth
because i didn't know you know i didn't
know what to do and then i just got up
and left
i always wondered what that woman was
thinking like this little redheaded boy
came over
to visit my our our daughter today honey
he came in he didn't say a word then he
left
it's an odd little fella i remember
there was another girl i had a crush on
there was these two twins when i was in
first grade and i had a crush on one of
them
and uh the other one had this giant pen
which i thought was the coolest thing
ever even though it was pink
it was just a giant pen which was
amazing in the early 70s like where
there was no [ __ ] computers and [ __ ]
i guess they were but computers were
gigantic
so she dropped it on the floor and she
didn't realize it and i took it
and then i started writing with it
what's funny was
the way they had the desk set up they
had like us in like
little groups of four and we faced each
other
and she was diagonal to me and i'm
writing with this giant pink pen
and she's going that's my pen and i was
like no it isn't it's mine
so she's like an idiot then she tells
the teacher
and then she's going billy is that your
pen and i was like yes
and then the girl's going no it was my
pen and i was going
no it isn't it's my pen and then she the
teacher's just like i don't think your
mom would buy you a pink pen
and she took it and gave it back to the
girl
and you know as a little kid like the
embarrassment of that goes away like
eight seconds later you can't even
remember like
you don't have like the mental capacity
like did i just really try to pull that
off
you know why the [ __ ] would i do that
right so then
i remember i went out asked i had to go
to the bathroom so i went out to the
bathroom
and her twin sister the one i had to
crush on oh this was like the next day i
went out to go to the bathroom and
her twin sister who i had a crush on
came walking out at the same time and me
when she saw me she immediately put her
eyebrows down she goes
i heard what you did i heard you try to
steal my sister's pen
and i just looked at i think i said no i
didn't and i just walked away and that
was the end of that romance
um oh there's a lot of sad stories
i don't know i haven't had a fight since
like [ __ ] seventh grade and i and i
i was gonna say and i lost as i recall
like you forget getting your ass kicked
um oh god i took a bad one you know when
you lose so bad you
can feel your hair
that's how much my [ __ ] head was on
fire like i could almost like
close my eyes and mentally count the
[ __ ] hair follicles that's how bad i
lost that fight
holy [ __ ] with my [ __ ] uh was it my
left ear or my right ear one of them was
like so [ __ ] hot
and it was just ringing
uh you never thought like your shirt
could hurt you until you got into like a
fight remember that somehow your [ __ ]
collar your shirt would leave like these
ligature marks on your neck
like how did that happen
um jesus [ __ ] christ that was a good
one
for the other person not for me then
that was the end of my [ __ ] fighting
career
um oh i had a bad fighting career you
know i i [ __ ] uh i lost to a girl
when i was in the third grade
she was in fifth grade though and i got
to tell you something that was a big
deal okay and if conor mcgregor can keep
talking about
how he went up a couple of weight
classes then i could make a [ __ ]
excuse
that this she was in fifth grade all
right she had me by like i don't know
six inches and above she was she was a
big girl
and i was trying to get the attention of
her her sister who was in the third
grade and she had she'd taken the
kickball from me
and i playfully went up there to take it
back from her but i grew up well i had
was brothers so i didn't know how to
[ __ ]
interact with females so i took it away
the way i would take it from my little
brother i
[ __ ] ripped it away and she was near
the school
and me ripping it away caused her to
careen into the school which we all know
are made out of bricks
because of the three little pig story
right so it's made out of [ __ ] bricks
and she hit her head on it
and started to cry and i was and i was
like and i didn't know what to do
[ __ ] my wife cried last week i didn't
know what to do then you think i know
what to do 40 [ __ ] years ago
i didn't right so she started [ __ ]
crying
and outta nowhere because the third
graders in the fifth graders had the
same [ __ ] recess
she came out of [ __ ] nowhere she came
out of [ __ ] nowhere
and uh just proceeded to just fight i
can't really remember what it was it was
just it was i just remember it was
coming from above
i don't know exactly what she hit me
with it was fists but
i don't know if they were hammer fists i
don't know what but she [ __ ] killed
me and he all kills me is i held it
together
i [ __ ] held it together afterwards
you know where you want to cry but
you're like i'm not gonna cry
you're trying to walk upright you know
with your head's a little cocked and i
was trying to just [ __ ] walk away
and um i was
i was all good and i got about five feet
away
and then this other girl goes she
shouldn't have done that to you
and then i [ __ ] burst it out crying
oh it was a long sad
sordid [ __ ] tales of my fights um
but dude it had a lot of hat did you
bill you cried after a woman beat you up
you know what i mean
anyways um she wasn't a woman she was a
child so was i
you know when i look back at if i just
[ __ ] just had a little more head
movement and i went for a single leg
takedown
you know what i mean i think i could
have had her but you know that [ __ ] was
not mainstream back then so
uh you know i didn't get the underhooks
going and there was no way to get the
triangle going with the uh the figure
four leglock so i lost that one there
where do you think that comes from uh
the desire to kind of be a
you know a [ __ ] disturber like that you
know um
that was sort of my my the family i grew
up in
it i remember describing it one time to
a therapist
and he sort of described it like lord of
the flies
because i had i had like i had four
brothers and a sister and it just it was
a pecking order
like you know my dad sort of [ __ ] with
all of us
right my older brother you know mess
with me on down then i messed with
you know everybody beneath me and it
literally went all the way down to the
dog and like everybody [ __ ] with the dog
and we had this little west highland
terrier and we turned it into like an
attack dog
like we started off played like the
glove game we you took a gardener glove
you sort of mushed it in his face
right it bit your face no and then yeah
eventually it did it it
ended up biting too hard so then it
became like a hockey stick not like hard
just like you're digging for a puck in
the corner
and at that point it learned how to do
that [ __ ] you know
what they bite and they they do like
that they're trying to like break the
neck
that's why they do that [ __ ] and uh we
thought it was hilarious but then the
dog started doing it to us and one day i
was [ __ ] with it while i was eating
and it actually caught me in the face it
got me like i had to get stitched my
dad's a dentist so i actually went in
and he he stitched me up your dad
stitched you up
yeah he used to do it a lot at home
because uh
i don't know i don't like talking about
this [ __ ] too much because it's a little
bizarre i think nowadays the way people
are grow up but yeah we used to
this is what happened we would get into
fights me and my brothers
and someone would end up needing
stitches and we always said the exact
same lie
i was running through the woods and i
tripped that's what we would say and
we'd always cover like one time i picked
a big rock up
and i threw it at my brother's head i
just i don't know why i did it i
i sort of threw it this direction i
didn't think it was going to hit him and
i
nailed him right on top of the head and
i apologized
and he was you know and then he's what
happened i was right
and i tripped it was a lot of that there
was no internet there was no
[ __ ] things there was nothing to do
my brother i saw one time he jumped out
of a tree
and there was this stick that was
pointed up in the air and he landed on
it
and for half a second was like impaled
on it and he looked so ridiculous
we were laughing our asses off including
him he was laughing because he felt
stupid
but then when he landed he left his
shirt up he was bleeding and then of
course you know once you saw blood
you were freaking out so then my we
would go in
and my dad be like oh for christ's sake
i don't need this [ __ ] he'd take you
upstairs
and go in the bathroom and then like
whoever was the
the oldest had to like assist was
basically what happened
i remember i got over being queasy with
head injuries but when my brother
with his chest it was a little bit of
tissue not to gross you out but i really
i almost passed out it was [ __ ] nasty
i didn't realize dentists were so uh
surging no no my dad my dad's hardcore
he was actually uh
he just does dentistry when he's like
you know that's like whittling to him
no he used to work on babies with cleft
palates that was the funny thing about
my
dad so by the time he got home his
patience
it was it was over so i mean we kind of
he was like uh sort of
mike ditka meets uh like a bookworm
because he was like a really smart guy
but he definitely had uh he definitely
had a level of intensity yeah that you
didn't mess with you know
he's a great guy got to throw that in i
was getting nervous
you know because when you talk about
this [ __ ] people people come up like
dude that's hilarious my dad was just
like it
or you get these people like oh my god
he felt like a monster he's like
he's a [ __ ] took us you know took us to
church every week made sunday breakfast
taught me how to drive
when i was like 12 back when uh
malls weren't open on sunday and we'd go
down there he taught me on on a stick
yeah let's see i uh we're about the same
age i wanted to ask you what you're 53
yep yeah
well 42 yeah 42. i just turned 39
and i was going to ask you what your
favorite thing was about growing up in
the 70s
because when you mentioned playing in
the woods and getting impaled on sticks
and not having the internet these are
the kinds of things that i did
yeah the games like i mean when it
rained out there was this we lived on a
busy street and there was this
area that this big puddle would grow up
would just sort of build
and would get to a certain level my
mother was fine with it we'd go out
with t-shirts and our shorts and we
would walk and we'd stand on the side of
the road and point at it
as motorists came by and these people
would drive their cars towards
five like basically toddlers to like a
nine-year-old
like god knows if it's too deep it might
cont make you drive over they didn't
give a [ __ ] it was the 70s
and they would just drive into it and
all this dirty
puddle water would wash over us and my
mother would [ __ ] hose us down
outside dry us off and then we we
we'd have dinner that's one thing i
actually looking back was great about
the 70s was i was allowed to have a
childhood
i was a lot like i did all this [ __ ] it
wasn't
uh you know i mean occasionally someone
would get a dirty magazine and
it would be like this unreal thing but
like i when i was a kid
thought you know right up until like the
age of like 10 or 11 i thought like
where i put it in
i thought it was right in front on a
female i thought it was literally
if it didn't make any sense that where
where it is i mean it makes sense now
but just i had no no idea but now
if i knew what to click as a
three-year-old i could just hit images
and see it right innocence is gone yeah
it is
and uh now now we're kind of told i
would think people are more told what
they're supposed to do for fun now like
you you have to go and be a little more
creative back in the 70s kind of
invent things and you could just open
the door and you could go outside and
there was no worry of of uh
of of any sort of like anything was
going that's what i remember my mother
would just shoot she
worked uh the late shift and she would
open the door
and she would just send us outside and
then would literally ring a
dinner bell for us to come in and we we
would just you know we did all sorts of
[ __ ]
that she had you know rode our bikes to
mcdonald's one time on the side of the
highway she had no idea
like a [ __ ] like a nine and a seven
year old and nobody stopped
people just kept going like there was
really no
uh i don't know